yes I'll be on detecting Satori
where are you from originally I'm from
Chicago and I'm down here for 20 years
20 years and what's your drug of choice
here
I'm heroin 12 years years did you do
drugs as a kid yeah and I did a pot and
methamphetamine cocaine could easily
serve 15 a boyfriend forever
yeah did your parents I had one parent
and by their
drug addict
I already picked organic from the get-go
and what do you do for money now some
campaign um I prostitute yeah it's it's
very dangerous I almost got killed a
couple times
I had some guy being I had been
gang-raped I was put into a
stir well and was gang-raped
in the first day I had a guy hit me in
the head with a 2x4 and I didn't want to
go to the hospital because I had heroin
on me so I just put it bandaid on our
Nate and went back out did it again
you know just bad just a bad environment
it's dangerous you never know it's gonna
happen reduce the attack um whatever I
can do to I did I had my children were
taking away from me
they were five and seven because I was a
heroin addict
and I went to prison and I couldn't get
clean for possession we still are under
cloud I could to it on the cover cop if
I could take it all back I would
as a major grader at my life
take it back I would I started
biggest mistake you ever made coming out
here clean did you regret thing yeah I
was clean for a while I was in prison
when I got out of my truck program and I
left the program and you said [ __ ] it
you know why should I stay clean you
know there's no reason for me to stay
clean you lost my kids I lost everything
so I really didn't care for liver died